here's what would happen if you jumped  into a pool of bromine  standing on the edge of this pool your  mouth nose and eyes would quickly become  irritated taking a breath your vocal  cords would close up blocking airflow to  your lungs once you took the plunge into  the liquid you'd feel a cool sensation  of relief for a few seconds until your  whole body started to feel like it was  on fire and your skin was burning off  oops too late to turn back now the  chemical burns you get would cause your  skin cells to start dying if you  swallowed any bromine it would burn your  stomach lining leading to  gastrointestinal perforation if you swam  to safety and got yourself to a hospital  you'd likely survive as long as you  haven't been exposed for too long but  you might suffer muscular degeneration  of the heart or memory loss you'd be in  danger even before dipping a toe into  that pool but if you took the risk